the few words spoken by Ganondorf in the
opening of Tears of the Kingdom reveal
exactly how the game's timeline and
story work let me explain how if you're
a Zelda fan and even if you're not you
may know that the series and timeline
wonkiness are connected Concepts
Nintendo has been liberal with how
they've used time and time travel
throughout the series and that has led
to a variety of timelines and possible
inconsistencies in looking at tears of
the Kingdom we could worry that the same
issues might arise but luckily ganon's
words help us out they show that he
recognizes our protagonists and this is
pivotal this fact clarifies the timeline
and shows us that it's both sensible and
consistent from here on out I'll be
diving into spoilers for the main story
of Tears of the Kingdom because I can't
talk much about all the time elements
without spoiling the main story I will
also not be worrying too much about how
this game interacts with the broader
Zelda timelines because I value my
sanity and comment section to get us
started we need to set up an an outline
of what happens since the game throws
time travel into the mix as soon as it
begins we open with Zelda and Link
coming across what is basically a mummy
who seems to be familiar with him Zelda
then makes contact with a secret Stone
and is sent back in time link is
transported by a glowing arm and wakes
up after some small passage of Time
Zelda is gone and we as link set out on
our journey to find her and save her
rule from the newly onset upheaval
typical start of a hero's journey but
right before we get to Hyrule proper we
see an echo of Zelda that gives us the
recall ability then we super recall the
corrupted Master Sword back in time to
Zelda before getting a totally unrelated
shot of clouds then we travel through
the game and on the way we find Geo
Cliffs which reveal memories however
these memories are not from Link's life
like in breath of the wild instead they
are scenes from the far past where Zelda
was transported to through the memories
we learned the whole backstory to the
founding of Hyrule and the imprisoning
of Ganon for this video the key points
we need to know are the details about
Zelda being there and becoming a sage of
time she was taken in by the first king
and queen of Hyrule raru and Sonia whom
she talked about link with and she
helped raru and five other sages fight
and imprisoned Ganon and then after
Ganon is sealed that's when Zelda
receives the master sword from the
future realizing what she can do to help
Zelda takes the master sword and
consumes her secret Stone turning her
into an immortal dragon in this state
Zelda is Immortal and she can bathe The
Sword in sacred light to strengthen it
then at least tens of thousands of years
go by possibly including every single
other Zelda game eventually in the
present we find dragon in Zelda and get
the upgraded master sword from her then
at the game's finale we fight Ganon The
Demon King and Ganon the demon dragon
Zelda helps best the Beast and after the
anime villain goes nuclear the spirits
of rauru and Sonia help link revert
Zelda back to human form a few cutscenes
go by in the game and time Loop are over
so that's a brief summary of The Game's
story in terms of time travel laid out
the loop would look like this Zelda and
Link happen upon an imprisoned Ganon who
recognizes them Zelda is sent to the
Past via secret Stone and her time power
in the past Zelda helps the war effort
tells the crew about link and becomes a
sword-infused Immortal dragon in the
present link gets a new arm sends the
sword back in time and Ventures around
Hyrule eventually he gets the sword out
of dragon Zelda blows up Ganon and
transforms Zelda back into Hylian after
that the game and time Loop are over now
there is one key detail in this Loop
that explains it all it's the fact that
Ganondorf recognized eyes Link and Zelda
from the very beginning before we see
Zelda go back in time this one detail
establishes what kind of time travel is
happening and it ensures that the
timeline of Tears of the kingdom is
consistent and believable but we can't
go any further here without talking
about a big something called metaphysics
which is a section of philosophy that
deals with fundamental questions of
being of what is in this case we need to
look at the metaphysics of time we need
to know what time is to figure out what
kind of time travel makes sense so
bastardizing thousands of years of
philosophical Toil and debate we can
very crudely set up a dichotomy one view
of time called eternalism and an
opposing view of time called presentism
here eternalism means all time is real
the past the present and the future are
all equally real in this view there is
no objective flow of time the present is
not privileged it is just all that we as
humans can experience if anyone has read
slaughterhouse 5 this is kind of how
time is depicted from the alien's point
of view on the other time hand we have
presentism where only the present is
real yeah the names aren't great I know
but surprisingly this isn't even the
most generic name used for this view
presentism can be intuitive we go
through time only feeling the present so
it's reasonable to think it exists in a
privileged way different from the past
and the future but intuition can be
deceiving developments in physics namely
in relativity have led many scientists
and philosophers to siding with a view
of time more in line with eternalism
than presentism in a survey of
philosophical positions a larger share
of philosophers said they believe in or
lean towards eternalism more than any
other view but that's just saying
philosophers have unintuitive views
which is not very shocking and not
necessarily convincing so let's Circle
back what do these creatively named time
theories even have to do with Zelda
remember how he said that ganondorf's
little zinc quips were really important
well that's because they point to the
world of Tears of the Kingdom as one
where eternalism is true and that would
mean time travel has a lot better chance
of making sense to explain what I mean
presentism makes time travel pretty hard
at best and basically impossible at
worst to start most of the philosophers
that do think presentism is true in our
world don't think time travel is even
possible under their view the view makes
time travel hard because it is
explicitly all about the present but
let's give presentism a try that might
make the issues more clear let's say
time travel is possible because when
someone goes to a different time they
experience that time as the present well
if only the present is real and nothing
from the non-existent past or future
compels certain action in the present
and what do I mean by that well in the
game operating in presentism Zelda goes
back in time and can act freely as that
old time is her new present her life
during the upheaval period isn't real
because it's now in the future so it
doesn't dictate her actions she can help
raru and act as we see her do in game
but she also has the option to act
against rauru she even could have
intentionally or not done something to
change the past and disrupt her family
line the Royal line that started with
rauru and Sonia for instance a
theoretical child of rauru and Sonia
could have been caught up in Zelda's
Light Dragon Blast and then poof no
royal family for Hyrule and how would
Zelda even exist since she's of the
royal family and we don't even need
something so Grand If Zelda could change
the past when going back to it then she
would change it just by showing up in
presentism when Hyrule was founded
Zelda's future time didn't exist because
it was the future so she obviously
couldn't have time traveled back to be
at the founding because she didn't exist
she was only in the future but then
during Zelda's time she can time travel
back because she has time powers in her
present and her present is now real but
if she does this she is changing the
founding time of Hyrule from one that
came and went without her to one that
came and went with her that is a clear
change presentism says that non-present
times aren't real so Zelda's showing up
in the past would necessarily be a
change from the first time that past
occurred before she ever existed with no
rules barring what could happen Zelda
could have changed the past and thereby
prevented her ancestral line from
eventually producing her and then we
would have a contradiction a Zelda in
the past that has been changed such that
Zelda was never born in the present and
then how did Zelda ever time travel in
the first place we could explain this
away with some parallel universe or
timeline reasoning or some wonky
invisible rules on past interactions but
those explanations kind of sidestep the
problem maybe they're justified in the
grand scheme of logical thinking but for
this video they're unsatisfying a time
travel that avoids the contradiction
altogether is a better more sensible
kind of time travel in my book so there
we have the issue with presentism it
allows for contradictions so what about
eternalism well if we look at what
happens in game we will see that
eternalism is the best description for
what actually does occur and it just so
happens to also give us a smoother more
consistent story
eternalism says that all times are real
there is no objective and singular flow
of time from past to present to Future
this means that Zelda going back in time
doesn't change the past her existence
during the present was always real so
she had always time traveled back to the
founding of Hyrule the founding and
imprisoning fight with Ganon always
featured her it was never a version of
any of these events without her Zelda
did not change the past she simply
fulfilled it and we know that this is
what happened because of ganondorf's
dialogue before any time travel is shown
he recognizes and remarks about both
Link and Zelda this means that the
Ganondorf we see in the game's beginning
is 100 the same Ganondorf no time or
timeline changes as the one that was
imprisoned with the aid of a
time-traveling Zelda she would have had
to have been in the past for Ganondorf
to recognize her in the present she also
needed to be in the past to tell rauru
about link for raru to then tell Gannon
about link to have Ganon know who link
is as he clearly does in the opening
eternalism allows for time travel that
doesn't change the past the past always
exists with the time traveling having
occurred during it this avoids any
contradiction because right from the
get-go we know Zelda's actions don't
cause her Line's end or any other
unforeseen consequence this is because
the past that produced Zelda was always
the past that had her actions in it
zonai Zelda was always baked in the
dialogue from Ganondorf lets us confirm
that the world of Hyrule is no different
the moment before Zelda time travels
than the moment after she does because
of this I think we can say that the time
travel and tears of the Kingdom make
sense the past isn't changed so no
contradictions or inconsistencies need
to be worried about no alternate
universes or new timelines have to be
created timeline we already the fans can
rest easy for once so that gives us a
timeline for tears of the Kingdom that
seems sensible fully explained and
philosophized let me know in the
comments if I missed any major time
inconsistencies subscribe if you enjoyed
and now let me get back to my poorly
made contraptions